in 1954 Anna Hodges was saved by a
meteorite 12:45 and this comes through
the roof but hit you she was napping
when the rock crashed through her
ceiling and bounced off the radio into
her stomach because it was small her
injuries were minor but much bigger
objects have collided with earth 65
million years ago a rock ten kilometers
wide slammed into the Gulf of Mexico an
event that likely caused dinosaurs to go
extinct elsewhere mammoth meteorites
have been discovered everywhere from the
u.s. to Russia and blasted craters in
North America Australia and Africa
falling objects from the sky have always
fascinated humans but they have also
made us fearful making us wonder whether
someday a giant asteroid could come for
us in movies like deep impact and
Armageddon those fears are played out
reached in heroes save the day you might
think this only happens in Hollywood but
that's not exactly true there is a small
chance a really really small chance of a
large asteroid hitting Earth so
scientists are getting ready just in
case
asteroids are hunks of rock that weren't
big enough to become planets when the
solar system formed smaller asteroids
are called meteoroids and when they fall
through Earth's atmosphere they become
meteors if they make it to the surface
they're called meteorites between 1988
and 2017 NASA counted over 700 fireballs
created by objects entering our
atmosphere in order to detect asteroids
NASA takes multiple pictures of the
night sky and uses computers to scan for
moving objects as Earth orbits
scientists make several observations
from different locations to detect how
close the asteroids are to Earth here
the nearest objects are labeled in green
at least 16,000 of them have been
classified as near-earth meaning they
orbit within roughly a third of the
distance from the Sun and based on the
object speed and brightness scientists
can map a trajectory to predict whether
it will collide with earth the impact
energy of a 10-meter object just a
little smaller than a school bus would
be 100 kilotons but the larger the
object the nastier the impact a
meteorite just a little larger than the
Great Pyramid at Giza at about 150
meters would generate 288 megatons of
energy for reference the number of
megatons in the payload of the Castle
Bravo hydrogen bomb was only 15 but
asteroids don't need a hit earth to
cause damage in 2013 a 17 meter wide
meteor exploded over Chelyabinsk Russia
before it ever reached the ground in the
resulting shockwave released about 440
kilotons of energy that damaged
structures and injured over 1500 people
following that event in Russia u.s.
politicians called on NASA to ask about
the threat of future collisions if we
saw one coming toward Omaha what could
they do about it and I said they could
use a laser first of all it would not be
practical to have a laser powerful
enough to split
and half their questions sounded like
plot lines for a new blockbuster but
their ideas we're not actually that far
off how far inland could a you know a
reasonably sized asteroid make water
come in scientists have analyzed how
asteroid impacts would kill people and
getting hit by the ejecta meaning space
rock and other debris it kicks up is one
of the least likely ways to die the most
lethal cause is violent wind generated
by the impact blast followed by
scorching heat in massive tsunamis the
odds of a near Earth object strike
causing massive casualties and
destruction of infrastructure are very
small but the potential consequences are
so large that it makes sense
to take the risk seriously Norma gettin
annihilation is avoided by nuking the
killer asteroid but in real life our
ability to prevent impact depends on how
big it is and when we detected
a 140 meter wide space rock is large
enough to destroy a city and if it were
on a path to collide with earth in less
than a year the only thing to do would
be evacuating attack zone but if we are
lucky enough to spawn an asteroid 7 to
10 years out NASA would have enough time
to try deflecting the object which they
could do a number of ways first NASA
could launch a spacecraft to act as a
battering ram and if the asteroid is far
enough out it would only need to be
pushed a few centimeters off course to
avoid hitting earth right now NASA is in
the early stages of Dart the double
asteroid redirection test which will try
out this approach by trying it on a
non-threatening asteroid called diddy
moon which will pass near earth in 2022
another method would be using something
called a gravity tractor which pulls the
asteroid in a new direction and points
it away from Earth theoretically a
spacecraft could do this by hovering
near an object to create a slight
gravitational attraction that can be
used to redirect the asteroid the third
option would be to go full Hollywood and
use a nuclear device to vaporize part of
the surface what you can do in principle
if you have a very powerful laser is to
cause Jets of material heated by the
laser to fly off of the asteroid and
that is essentially the equivalent of a
jet engine pushing the asteroid off
course so far NASA hasn't found any
asteroids big enough to threaten earth
but we haven't been searching that long
there's still lots of space to survey
and the big one might be on its way we
just haven't found it
you
[Music]